You’ve probably seen preserved deer and
antlers displayed on the walls of wood cabins,
but the type of preservation scientists are
involved in is a whole different story.
Hi guys, Lissette here for DNews. Just recently,
the California Academy of Sciences gave us
an inside look at what happens behind museum
exhibits. We had the opportunity to participate
in the live preservation of a hummingbird
and got an up-close look at preserved animals that
are now EXTINCT.
For more on the process of taxidermy, head over to Seeker Stories
to see how merging your love of science and art can lead to an awesome career.
Now that you got the skinny on mammal preservation, let us know how you feel about preserving your own body.
Is cryogenics something you’d consider? Share your thoughts in the comments
and remember to subscribe so you never miss an episode of DNews. Thanks for watching.